dr fauci once again under fire accused
of flip-flopping
the white house's top health expert now
saying this about outdoor covert
transmission and mask
guidelines it's pretty common sense now
that
outdoor risk is really really quite low
particularly
i mean if you were a vaccinated person
wearing a wearing a mask outdoors i mean
obviously the risk is miniscule
reports say updated guidance on wearing
masks
outdoors from the cdc could arrive as
early as tomorrow
now that comes as a new study suggests
our social distancing rules may have
been misguided from the very start
that study claims that standing apart at
60 feet
is no safer than at six feet and that
exposure time indoors is actually
far more important jesse the cdc
changes guidelines as they get new
information we're now more than a year
into this pandemic situations
change so isn't that reason to celebrate
that they're being honest and
straightforward
yeah like three months late juan i was
listening to howard stern this morning
he was talking about how he goes outside
with
his bes his wife beth and they go on
walks and he wears a mask and his wife
beth doesn't
and he had on dr agus chief medical
correspondent for cbs news and he says
doctor
who's right and the doctor says there's
two
answers there's the personal answer and
then there's the public policy health
answer personal answer
is sure you don't have to wear a mask
when you're vaccinating you go outside
but the answer from a public policy
health perspective is
we want to continue to wear masks the
message is when you're wear outside
you wear a mask and that's the problem
there's a difference between telling the
truth
and messaging and the american people
don't want messaging anymore we can go
online and we can see the statistics
we see the numbers we see the trends we
have all the studies
it's not like 20 years ago when you have
to message us to death about
a war or you know a pandemic or anything
like that we get it
like fauci's on there the other day
yesterday saying there's
60 000 new infections a day i said that
sounds high
i checked it out we're at 32 000 new
infections a day
he's bsing us and he's doing that to
message us to death
we just want the truth dr fauci
so dagon we are seeing a surge in rural
communities and especially
and this is a surprise to me among
younger people people in like 30 40
50 higher rates of infection for them
so you know what are we to think about
at this moment
in dealing with the virus if you've been
vaccinated you don't have to wear a mask
outside period if you've had the viru
i've got antibodies when i go outside
i don't wear a mask if the cdc comes out
and says hey you've been vaccinated
don't wear a mask outside
this is the first time that they will
have delivered tangible benefits to
people
and it could get people to go and get
vaccinated who are reticent
to go and get the shot what 22 percent
said in the fox news poll they don't
plan to get it
but in terms of messaging i was sitting
in the lobby of my building a few days
ago
and some dude was walking out and like
and was shocked he didn't have a mask on
i went
you've been vaccinated you don't need a
mask outside and he looked at me
like i flashed him and flashed him
a reptilian undercarriage
nice yeah greg
i'm just thinking about that what an
image degan hey look look
looking to fauci for leadership is like
looking to the view for brain cells
it's uh it's that's not his role uh
and and he's just there to just spout
whatever he has to say
uh for example they say now that uh what
60 feet away is no safer than six feet
i anticipate to anticipate the media
saying okay
we should stay 61 feet apart just for
the summer
61 feet apart
i'll do it too i will do it i'm with you
degan i love walking around without my
mask on
i can't tell if the people are reacting
with the past
with the passing scowl because they
recognize me
[Laughter]
or it's because i'm masculine
[Laughter]
so dana they're saying shortly there'll
be more vaccine than people who want to
get
the vaccinations shouldn't people just
get
vaccinated look it it is a personal
choice but i think that it does provide
you a lot of freedom and confidence
i walked around all day outside in new
york city on saturday i didn't wear a
mask i didn't get one scout i didn't get
one negative comment
because i think people are realizing
that it doesn't make sense anymore
i think the cdc knew this about masking
outside and they have held the
announcement to give it to president
biden so that he could do it on his
first 100 days because he
said on january 21st i'm just going to
ask you to do it for 99 days guys
so tomorrow at 1 30 watch he's going to
make this announcement
last thing i would say is there is no
rule that you have to do every
sunday show every week you don't have to
do it
dr fauci you don't have to take a day
off
all right